so part of the theme of the trilogy that
is missed opportunities taking the other
path and how you know relationships jobs
etc always imperfect from far away and
then you get close and you see that
nothing is really perfect in knowing
that are there ever acting rules that
you've romanticized that you've passed
on for whatever reason whether it was an
agent's advice that she kind of said you
know what I wish I had taken that path
instead about you but there's a lot of
reasons that go into well I might I've
turned down good parts before or I've
auditioned for movies really that I
should have tried harder to get over
something but I don't usually regret it
because wherever I was in my life at
that point
that's why I wasn't interested in that
role just I wasn't I mean I've read a
script before for example I thought was
just terrible and then I saw the movie
the movie was great it was obvious that
I didn't understand the script yes I was
honest in the wrong actor because I
didn't get it yeah I mean it's happened
to me to just say no to films that end
up being successful or they act to end
up when I turned down my god I was like
I had heard of Steven Spielberg I had
heard a Lincoln I was weird why are they
talking funny it was like no I mean
regrets are just like what you know I'm
not a person that's big on regrets like
I'm like moving forward and I'm actually
in a way like those things I said no to
brought a certain famed
people so but in a way kind of I know my
life my path was pretty much meant to go
into a direction of writing and
directing and and I think if I didn't
make the choices of maybe more like
successful big films and stuff it's also
maybe because I was like looking for
what I really want to do is my life
which I found so you know I I have no
regrets
so I'm exactly where I want to be I know
that's crazy to say that right but it's
true I am where I want to be exactly and
I'm looking forward to doing more of
that